filtering data is one of the more
difficult aspects of working firebase in
this episode I'm going to cover four
different techniques you can use to
filter data by multiple values at the
same time the goal is to achieve similar
results to what you would expect by
using the where clause in a sequel
database in this app we have a
collection of animals and we want to be
able to filter these animals by three
different attributes at the same time we
want to filter by an exact string match
for the family for a weight range for
the animals weight and boolean value for
whether or not the animal is endangered
in the database we just have a
collection of animals and each animal
has the properties that we want to
filter by if you've worked with
angularfire - you're probably used to
making queries like this where you
return a firebase list observable and
pass a query to sort by a certain value
this works great when you want to filter
by just one single value but if you have
multiple values you have to take a
different approach the best option is to
filter the list client-side that is
after you've received the data from
firebase the main drawback is that you
have to load the entire collection into
memory which may not work for larger
data sets in this example I'm going to
create a client-side filtering system
that allows you to add and remove
various filtering rules to your data
start by importing the angularfire
database and we're also going to make
extensive use of lodash in this example
we set a variable for animals which will
always be the full data set pulled from
firebase and filtered animals will be a
copy of it with the filter rules applied
to it this allows us to add and remove
filters on the fly next we set some
variables for the attributes that we
want to filter then we create another
object that will keep track of the
active filters applied to the data set
during ng on an it we return the
firebase list observable and subscribe
to it and the value that it emits will
be the animals variable and then we
apply any active filters to it this
allows us to keep the database in sync
in real time the next step is to
actually filter the data we do this
using the lodash filter function first
we pass it the full data set and then we
use another lodash function called
conform
conforms takes an entire object of
functions that return either true or
false this allows us to filter multiple
attributes at the same time check out
the full lesson link in the description
if you want more detail than that from
there we can create our first filter I
want to make these as reusable as
possible so I pass a property as an
argument and a rule which is the value
that that property must conform to in
this app every animal has a family
property so we can pass it that property
and then set the rule to bird and that
will return all the birds in the
collection we can add any filters of any
degree of complexity using this
technique in this example we filter all
the values that are greater than the
rule you can add any logic to this
function
it just has to return true or false in
this app we're using it to filter the
weight property on animals greater than
a certain threshold and the last filter
we're going to setup is a boolean filter
this one operates a little bit different
because if it's false we want to remove
the filter altogether and if it's true
we can just return true to remove a
filter all we have to do is delete that
property from the filters object now
let's see how we have everything wired
up in the HTML we start by creating a
select box and bind that to ngmodel and
our family variable in the type script
then we can call the filter exact method
passing it the family property as well
as the family variable that's being set
by ngmodel to remove a filter we just
see if that family variable to find and
if so we allow the user to click a
button that runs the remove filter
method for the weight greater than we
follow the same basic process just
passing it a different variable and
different property name at this point
you might notice how these filter
methods can be reused on any infinite
number of properties and to show the
animals all we have to do is loop over
the filtered animals variable now when
we go back to the app we have a basic
client-side filtering system all set up
so what if your data set is too large
for client-side filtering the next
option would be to create composite keys
the idea behind this is to combine
multiple key value pairs into a single
key value pair the main drawback is that
it's only really practical
or up to three properties after that
you'll have way too many key value
combinations to keep track of if we were
to implement this in our app this is how
the composite keys would look in the
database we would combine the keys and
then combine their values allowing us in
an indirect way to query for multiple
properties at once then we could use
these keys to query the database with
angularfire - just like normal if you
think this is the right approach for
your app there's also a library called
query base that does this for you
automatically it's experimental at this
point but might be something to look
into another way to filter by multiple
attributes in firebase is to use a tag
filtering strategy in this case you
would denormalize your data to keep
track of each item under a tag that it's
associated with this would allow you to
pull all the items associated with a
specific tag and then combine them
together you could either take the
intersection or the union of those keys
and then make a query for each item
individually you could use the
intersection helper from lodash and then
make requests for firebase object
observables based on the keys that are
returned and the last option I'm going
to talk about is using a third-party
service such as algo Lea or
elasticsearch I made a couple videos
recently about using algo Lea with
angular 4 and firebase and if you're
doing a lot of advanced filtering of
your data it's usually a good idea to
outsource this to a third-party service
data indexing is a rather high
maintenance and error-prone process so
mess around with third-party providers
before trying to do the entire thing
from scratch that's it for advanced
filtering of firebase if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
instead of joining our slack team if you
want to discuss this in more detail and
again support the channel become a pro
member at angular firebase comm for a
free copy of my book as well as one on
one project consulting thanks for
watching and I'll see you soon
you
[Music]